du virus continue à augmenter fortement
le taux d'incidence qui compte
vous le savez le nombre de nouvelles
contaminations par le virus par semaine
est en hausse constante
il était la semaine dernière à 83 cas
pour 100000 habitants
nous sommes ce soir à près de 95 cas
pour 100000 habitants et nous
dépasseront sans nul doute les 100 cas
pour 100000 habitants dans les
prochaines heures ou les prochains jours
le taux de reproduction du virus
ce facteur air que je vous ai déjà
également présenté plusieurs fois reste
au-dessus de 1
c'est un indicateur qui montre la
vitesse de circulation du virus qui est
un indicateur de l'évolution de
l'épidémie
c'est le nombre de personnes qu'une
personne malade va contaminer la semaine
suivante
je vous rappelle que ce r était beaucoup
plus élevé lors de la première vague
il était de l'ordre de 3 voire au delà
ce que vous voyez sur ce grave c'est
qu'il ya plusieurs méthodes pour évaluer
les facteurs r selon les admissions aux
urgences selon les appels à sos médecins
ou selon le nombre de diagnostics
réalisés par test pcr mais ils peuvent
varier mais ils sont constamment
au-dessus de 1
ils sont peu au dessus de 1 ces facteurs
est remis le reste peu au dessus de 1 ça
veut dire que si nous réalisons encore
quelques efforts dans notre quotidien
j'y reviendrais et si mauvais si nous
adoptons les bonnes mesures là où c'est
nécessaire nous pouvons le faire baisser
en dessous de 1 et ainsi réduire enfin
la circulation du virus
nous l'avons déjà fait collectivement au
printemps dernier l'autre indicateur
c'est le taux de positivité des tests je
vous le rappelle sur 100 tests réalisés
combien de tests reviennent positif la
semaine dernière je vous ai présenté un
taux à 5%
il est ce soir à 6%
la circulation du virus n'est évidemment
et malheureusement pas sans conséquence
la part des patients co lead dans nos
réanimation a commencé à réaugmenter
elle atteint désormais 19 % au niveau
national c'est à dire que il ya plus de
neuf cent cinquante patients atteints de
corona virus dans les réanimations
française la situation est préoccupante
également dans les services
d'hospitalisation
où il ya près de six mille malades
hospitalisés sur la seule journée d'hier
est d'ailleurs en moyenne depuis
quelques jours nous comptons plus de 600
admission par jour à l'hôpital et une
centaine d'admission dans les services
de réanimation
je vais vous donner le détail de la
situation en ile de france afin
d'illustrer l'inquiétude dont je vous
fais part ce soir
ce système de santé franciliens il est
désormais fortement mis en tension
il a déjà été au printemps dernier la
part d'activité liée au corps et la
virus aux urgences et est en lente
augmentation depuis la fin du mois de
juin
elle a doublé en quinze jours elle a
doublé en quinze jours elle est passée
de 2,2 pour cent à 4 % de l'activité des
urgences
le nombre de patients hospitalisés au
sein de la région est lui aussi en
augmentation très rapide on comptabilise
près de 1000 hospitalisations pour
coronavirus sur les sept derniers jours
contre 460 la semaine précédente là
aussi un doublement
plus marquant encore sur les près de
2000 patients hospitalisés avec le co
vide
trois cent cinq sont hospitalisés en
réanimation
soit 27 % de la capacité totale de
réanimation de la région contre 18% il
ya une semaine au rythme actuel avec
environ 50 entrées par jour en soins
intensifs en soins critiques dans les
hôpitaux parisiens de l'île de france
contre une quinzaine par jour il ya une
semaine on peut s'attendre à ce que 40%
des capacités régionales de réanimation
soit utilisé pour des patients qu'ovide
du 6 au 10 octobre
60% vers le 25 octobre et 85% aux
alentours du 11 novembre sur la
diapositive qui va s'afficher
vous avez la situation en région
auvergne rhône-alpes
qu'est ce que c'est que cette
diapositive elle est inspirée des
modélisations de l'institut pasteur et
tiennent compte de toutes les données
dont nous disposons sur la circulation
du virus pour pouvoir prédire par avance
quel sera l'impact sanitaire à quelques
jours et à quelques semaines ces
modélisations elles sont réactualisées
et chaque semaine elles ont été
réactualisés hier et elle nous montre
que nous nous inscrivons actuellement
dans la dynamique telles qu'elles
avaient été prévues par les premiers
modèles il y a une semaine il y a dix
jours et elle montre si vous lisez bien
ce graphe que d'ici ni aux alentours du
10 octobre
nous aurions atteint si la situation
devait évoluer de manière constante
le seuil qui correspond aux capacités de
places en réanimation dans la région et
quelques jours plus tard un peu plus
d'une semaine plus tard le seuil maximal
des places en réanimation dans la région
auvergne rhône-alpes
quand bien même nous aurions augmenter
ses capacités ce que nous sommes en état
de faire j'y reviendrai si je vous
montre cette diapositive c'est pas pour
faire peur outre mesure ça reste une
modélisation mais c'est pour vous dire
qu'il est encore temps d'agir et que les
mesures que nous prenons et j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure ont pour
objectif de faire mentir cette courbe ou
plutôt de sortir de cette trajectoire
est de protéger nos hôpitaux et nos
réanimation si nous ne prenons pas des
mesures rapidement nous risquons
d'atteindre une situation critique dans
certaines régions les plus touchées
et ce en quelques semaines je vous
montre ici la situation aux régions
auvergne et rhône alpes
d'autres régions peuvent être soumises
un fort stress hospitalier est en
réanimation est une autre différence
j'en ai parlé la semaine dernière avec
la première vague avec le printemps
dernier
c'est que nous ne pouvons pas nous
permettre de déprogrammer massivement
l'activité chirurgicale réglé parce
qu'il ya d'autres malades que les
malades qui ont le corona virus il ya
des malades qui ont un cancer qui doit
être opéré des malades qui doivent se
faire poser des prothèses en orthopédie
et qui ont parfois retarder leurs
opérations suffisamment longtemps
et puis les activités de greffes nous
devons protéger nos hôpitaux
nous devons protéger nos services de
réanimation nous devons protéger les
français
la détérioration de la situation m'amène
donc à délivrer un message solennel à
chacune et à chacun d'entre nous la
première clé nous la connaissons et nous
la détenons respect des gestes barrières
lavage des mains respect des distances
port du masque et plus globalement
réduction des interactions sociales et
vigie
hans collective autant dans la sphère
publique que dans la sphère privée
je sais et je mesure pleinement les
efforts que chacun d'entre nous réalise
au quotidien mais on peut pas être
extrêmement vigilant dans le métro dans
le bus à son bureau dans un commerce et
relâcher toutes formes de vigilance
contre quand on se retrouve dans un bar
ou chez soi en invitant des amis ou au
contact de sa famille on en a tous envie
mais il ne faut pas céder à cette
tentation
il faut pas multiplier les dîners il
faut éviter de sortir plusieurs fois par
semaine avec des personnes différentes
encore une fois si chacun de nous voit
un peu moins de personnes par jour c'est
un peu plus attention à la distance et
au respect des gestes barrières alors
nous réussirons à vaincre ce virus
certains pays ont parlé du concept de
bulles sociale c'est un peu le concept
dont je vous parle ce soir avec cet
effort collectif qui est la clé de notre
capacité à maîtriser le virus notre
stratégie vous la connaissez je l'ait
présenté la semaine dernière et le
président de la république et le premier
ministre l'ont validé est présenté elle
repose sur quatre piliers les gestes
barrière le triptyque tester alerté
protéger une stratégie différenciée de
mesures adaptées à chaque territoire et
enfin la protection des personnes âgées
et vulnérables
ce soir c'est sur le troisième pilier l'
approche territoriale dans la lutte
contre l'épidémie que je veux m'arrêter
pourquoi est-ce qu'on raisonne de cette
manière là de manière territoriale et de
manière différenciée
d'abord parce que le virus ne circule
pas de la même manière son les
territoires concernés les endroits où
circule très vite des endroits où ils
circulent moins vite
cela nous permet donc sur chaque
territoire d'appréhender la situation
avec des indicateurs très précis
quotidien et de prendre les mesures
adaptées en fonction de la situation
donc cette situation allait forcément
très variable selon les territoires et
métropole et vous allez avoir un tableau
qui vous est présentée et qui
l'illustrent
il faut donc pour chaque territoire
prend des mesures adaptées celles qui
permettront de poursuivre la vie
économique la vie culturelle la vie
sociale mais aussi de réduire et de
réglementer les événements et activités
dont on sait qu'ils sont
particulièrement propices à la
transmission est donc à la circulation
des virus
c'est un équilibre difficile nous ne
décidons pas tout seul d'en haut nous le
faisons grâce à une concertation étroite
avec les agences régionales de santé
avec les préfets et avec l'ensemble des
élus des territoires concernés
c'est pourquoi depuis plusieurs semaines
vous voyez des mesures qui sont
différentes mais elles peuvent être
différentes et être cohérente et elles
le sont cohérentes prise en fonction des
villes des métropoles parfois des
départements qui sont les plus touchés
c'est une des caractéristiques de la
situation actuelle c'est que la
circulation du virus est
particulièrement forte dans les endroits
où la population est concentrée c'est à
dire dans les métropoles
afin d'être le plus clair possible
je vais vous présenter les différents
niveaux d' alerte dans lesquelles les
départements peuvent se retrouver en
fonction de leur dynamique épidémique
pour classer les départements et les
territoires
nous nous fondons sur trois indicateurs
clés dans cette phase de l'épidémie
le taux d'incidence c'est ce qu'ils
mesurent donc l'intensité de la
circulation du virus et donc le nombre
de malades
le taux d'incidence pour les personnes
âgées de 65 ans et plus qui sont les
personnes les plus fragiles face au
risque de faire des formes graves
d'infection et enfin la part des
patients atteints de co vide dans les
réanimations c'est le reflet de l'impact
de l'épidémie sur notre système de santé
c'est notre boussole c'est ce qui
inspire les mesures protéger l'hôpital
protéger les réanimations protéger notre
système de santé
comme vous le savez depuis juillet
plusieurs départements ont
progressivement basculer de la zone
verte où le virus circule peu en zone
rouge où il circule activement
c'est à dire où l'on constate un taux
d'incidence supérieur à 50 nouveaux cas
pour 100000 habitants aujourd'hui
69 départements
on franchit ce seuil soit environ 7 sur
10 dans ces départements rouge
les préfets sont habilités à prendre des
mesures pour réduire le risque de
contamination ce qu'ils font pour
certains depuis le mois d'août
l'ampleur de ces mesures doit être
évidemment strictement proportionnées
aux risques ni trop peu ni crocs c'est
la raison pour laquelle le gouvernement
a retenu pour ces départements rouge
plusieurs seuils d'alert auxquels
correspondent différents niveaux de
mesures la zone alerte que vous voyez
c'est la zone où le virus circule
nettement ce sont les départements les
territoires dans lesquels le taux
d'incidence est supérieur à 50 et dont
je viens de parler la zone dite alerte
renforcée c'est la zone où le virus
circule très fortement y compris chez
les personnes fragiles chez les
personnes âgées
avec déjà des premiers impacts sur le
système de santé la zone d' alerte
maximale
c'est la zone où la situation épidémique
peut être qualifiée d' extrêmement
tendue avec des conséquences déjà lourde
sur le système sanitaire
si cette dernière zone d' alerte devait
être dépassée nous n'aurions pas d'autre
choix que de déclencher l'état d'urgence
sanitaire dans les territoires concernés
nous ferons et nous faisons tout pour
l'éviter et j'y reviendrai pour chacune
de ces zones des mesures adaptées sont
prises par les préfets en concertation
je le disais avec les élus locaux
ces mesures elles sont décidées toutes
les semaines et elles sont décidées pour
une période de 15 jours
elles sont naturellement réévaluée en
fonction de l'évolution de la situation
épidémique
la zone dallaire pour rentrer un peu
dans le détail elle se caractérise par
une circulation je le disais active du
virus
en pratique un taux d'incidence
supérieur à 50 cas pour 100000 habitants
mais pas une circulation intense chez
les populations âgées avec donc un taux
d'incidence qu'on caractérise en dessous
de 50 pour cent mille chez les personnes
âgées
et avec pas ou peu d'impact sanitaire en
tout cas un impact qui n'est pas fort
sur les réanimations dans l'ensemble de
ces territoires dans l'ensemble de ces
départements
le préfet est néanmoins habilité à
prendre toutes mesures qui lui
semblerait pertinente
seule une disposition est désormais et
sera désormais imposé à tous ses
départements rouge les fêtes les
mariages les tombolas les événements
associatifs les anniversaires les
communions devront se tenir en petit
comité
c'est à dire à moins de 30 personnes les
salles polyvalentes des salles des fêtes
et les autres établissements recevant ce
type d'événement devront respecter cette
jauge de 30 personnes pour la zone
maintenant d' alerte renforcée ce qui
fait basculer un territoire de zone d'
alerte alerte renforcée c'est bien
souvent d'ailleurs une métropole c'est
l'augmentation du taux d'incidence au
dessus de 150
c'est un taux d'incidence chez les
personnes âgées qui dépasse les 50 dans
cette zone d'alerté renforcée il ya une
circulation très intense du virus dans
la population générale et qui touche les
personnes fragile c'est un indice que la
situation sanitaire est amené à se
dégrader et que des mesures fortes sont
donc devenus indispensables pour freiner
enrayer la circulation du virus
c'est cette logique qui a été appliquée
à marseille à bordeaux et en guadeloupe
depuis deux semaines et dont j'ai
annoncé qu elle était appliquée à lyon
et à nice depuis la fin de la semaine
dernière compte tenu de la situation
épidémique de nouvelles métropoles que
j'avais d'ailleurs cité la semaine
dernière comme faisant l'objet d'une
vigilance particulière intègre désormais
cette zone d' alerte renforcée
il s'agit des métropoles de l'île de
toulouse de saint-etienne de rennes
paris ainsi que les départements de la
petite couronne
rouen grenoble et montpellier les
mesures qui s'appliqueront à compter de
samedi et à l'issue d'une concertation
entre le préfet et les élus locaux sont
les suivantes
abaissement de la jauge des
rassemblements à 1000 personnes sous
réserve que les protocoles sanitaires
ils soient strictement respectées
interdiction des grands événements
déclaré comme les fêtes locales ou les
fêtes étudiantes l'interdiction des
rassemblements de plus de 10 personnes
dans l'espace public tels que plage parc
fermeture anticipée des bars l'horaire
de fermeture étant décidée par le préfet
après concertation des élus
cette mesure sur les barres entrera en
vigueur lundi pour laisser le temps
utile à cette concertation
en tout état de cause les bars ne
pourront pas rester ouverts au delà de
22 heures dans l'ensemble de ces
territoires
la fermeture des salles de sport et des
gymnases
en effet ce sont des espaces confinés où
le port du masque est impossible voire à
minima complexe et qui sont des lieux
hélas de contamination important la
fermeture de toutes les salles des fêtes
et salle polyvalente pour les activités
festives et les activités associatives
cette dernière mesure entrera également
en vigueur lundi
je vous disais ces mesures pour tous les
territoires que j'ai cités vont faire
l'objet d'une concertation au cours des
48 prochaines heures
ces concertations permettront de les
préciser à la fois pour qu'elles soient
les plus efficaces possibles dans notre
objectif commun la lutte contre le virus
mais aussi évidemment les plus vivable
possible car il s'agit bien je le répète
de vivre avec le virus
au-delà de ces mesures de nature
réglementaire
nous devons dans ces métropoles plus
encore qu'ailleurs modifier nos
comportements et nos habitudes
le télétravail doit être favorisée
autant que possible en particulier pour
les publics vulnérables
c'est naturellement à chaque entreprise
à chaque administration de voir comment
il peut selon l'activité de chacun
développer au maximum le télétravail la
période récente nous a démontré que le
télétravail était à la fois possible et
précieux en cas de forte circulation du
virus
il faut donc dans les métropoles en
alerte renforcée et encore plus dans les
métropoles en alerte maximale
le développer très fortement nous devons
plus encore qu'ailleurs limiter les
rassemblements privé réservé ces moments
de rencontre à nos plus proches à nos
familles à nos amis tous les contacts
sociaux sans masque dans les espaces
clos que ces espaces soient publiques ou
qu'ils soient privés doivent être évités
au maximum ce n'est pas parce qu'on est
chez soi avec une dizaine d'amis que il
ya moins de risque que le virus circule
que si nous étions dans un lieu public
fermé avec la même dizaine d'amis enfin
nous portons une attention particulière
aux personnes âgées à elle plus encore
qu aux autres je demande la plus grande
vigilance
je sais combien elle est difficile cette
vigilance de tous les instants mais je
sais aussi combien elle est précieuse
compte tenu du risque de développer des
formes graves de la maladie les
personnes âgées à domicile sont appelés
à se protéger particulièrement en
adoptant des gestes barrières renforcée
mais sans se mettre à l'écart les
personnes âgées et les personnes
vulnérables doivent aussi vivre avec le
virus
si vous êtes isolé n'hésitez pas à
contacter votre mairie vous avez
également un numéro d' écoute et de
lutte contre l' isolement qui a été mis
en place par la croix rouge
le 09 70 28 30 00 nous avons tous une
responsabilité collective pour nos
proches pour qu'ils ne restent pas isolé
pour nos voisins
il faut que nous nous protégions mais il
faut aussi qu'on prenne soin d'eux en
plus des gestes barrières on peut
adopter des gestes solidaires on peut
passer des coups de fil peut prendre des
nouvelles vérifier si tout va bien la
protection n'est pas les allemands notre
attention sur la situation des personnes
âgées dans les ehpad cette fois ci est
évidemment particulièrement forte et le
président de la république l'a rappelé
hier au cours d'un déplacement les ehpad
sont invités à prendre des mesures de
protection renforcée tout en maintenant
l'indispensable lien avec les proches
rétablissement des visites sur rendez
vous avec des plages horaires
ap teheran verte le week end engagement
des proches à respecter les gestes
barrières politiques de dépistage
déterminée et renforcé avec des
campagnes de prévention à intervalles
réguliers
si la situation ne s'améliore pas dans
d'autres agglomérations
elle pourrait bientôt rejoindre la liste
de ces métropoles de ces territoires en
zone d'alerté renforcée je vais en citer
4 en particulier tours strasbourg dijon
et clermont-ferrand
si la situation se dégrade encore pour
les territoires qui sont déjà en alerte
renforcée
ils peuvent alors passé en territoire
dit en alerte maximale les seuils qui
détermine ce passage sont un taux
d'incidence supérieur à 250 pour 100000
habitants dans la population générale
un taux d'incidence supérieur à 100 pour
cent mille habitants
chez les personnes âgées et enfin un
impact mesurable significatif sur les
réanimations c'est à dire quant au moins
30 % des lits de réanimation à l'échelle
de la région sont occupés par des
patients atteints de co vide
j'insiste sur ce point vraiment lancé le
point le plus essentiel
il s'agit d'un niveau qui met dès lors
qu'on le conte latin fortement en
tension notre système sanitaire sont
concernés par ce passage en alerte
maximale
la guadeloupe et la métropole d'aix
marseille en guadeloupe parce que le
taux d'incidence encore progressé depuis
la semaine dernière il est passé de 250
à 290 le taux d'incidence pour les
personnes âgées a également progressé
il dépasse les 200 à marseille certains
diront n'y at-il pas un paradoxe puisque
on peut constater un frémissement
s'agissant de la courbe d'incidence et
d'un certain nombre d'indicateurs depuis
quelques jours je veux mettre deux
alertes
la première c'est que tous les experts
nous le disent il faut un temps long
pour considérer qu'un territoire est en
train
de gagner progressivement la bataille
contre la circulation du virus 3 4 jours
de stabilisation affiché ne suffisent
pas à considérer qu'on est véritablement
sur la bonne voie on peut évidemment
l'espérer si c'est le cas nous en aurons
la confirmation au cours des prochains
jours
les experts disent qu'il faut au moins
10 à 15 jours de réduction consécutive à
un minima de stabilisation de ces
indicateurs pour qu'on considère qu'on
est sur le chemin pour vaincre la
circulation du virus
la deuxième raison pour laquelle nous
basculons marseille fait que de fait le
taux d'incidence reste supérieur à 250
en population générale et il est de 180
donc très au delà du seuil pour les
personnes âgées de 65 ans et plus est
par ailleurs le taux d'occupation des
réanimations est supérieure à 30% pour
les seuls patients qu'aux vide
sur la seule journée d'hier 20 patients
ont été hospitalisés pour des formes
graves de kobe de 19 pour répondre à
cette situation
de nouvelles mesures s'appliqueront donc
à partir de samedi à l'issue de la même
manière d'une concertation avec le
préfet et les élus locaux
ces mesures j'ai conscience qu'elles
sont difficiles mais elles sont et nous
en sommes convaincus nécessaire il
s'agit tout d'abord de la fermeture
totale des bars et des restaurants de la
fermeture de l'ensemble des
établissements recevant du public
sauf s'il existe un protocole sanitaires
strictes déjà mis en place
à ce titre les lieux culturels comme les
théâtres les musées les cinémas
on dispose de protocoles sanitaires
strictes et ne sont donc pas concernés
par les mesures de fermeture et par
ailleurs nous incitons au maximum au
télétravail pour l'ensemble des
activités pour lesquelles c'est possible
dans ces territoires
ces dispositions elles sont temporaires
health concerne donc des zones d' alerte
renforcée des zones d' alerte maximale
elles sont malheureusement les seuls de
nature à limiter les contaminations
l'objectif est qu'elles ne durent pas
plus de deux semaines le temps de
freiner la propagation du virus
l impact très fortement certaines
entreprises certains secteurs notamment
les bars et les restaurants dans les
zones en alerte maximale toutes ces
entreprises
les restaurants de marseille les clubs
de sport etc seront financièrement
évidemment soutenu l'ensemble des
dispositifs qui ont été mises en place
au moment du confinement leur seront de
nouveau ouverts fonds de solidarité
quel que soit le secteur d'activité
exonération des cotisations sociales
activité partielle sans reste à charge
pour l'employeur
le ministre de l'économie et de la
relance bruno le maire aura l'occasion
d'y revenir très prochainement
si toutefois parce que évidemment nous
n'espérons pas mais si toutefois malgré
ces mesures la situation sanitaire
devait encore s'aggraver dans ces
territoires
nous n'aurions alors pas d'autre choix
que de basculer ces territoires
ces territoires concernés en état
d'urgence sanitaire
nous ne pourrons pas faire autrement si
les rennais mais si les réanimations
devait se remplir et saturé vous pouvez
le constater sur la carte
à date aucun territoire national n'est
concerné par ces mesures d' état
d'urgence sanitaire
par ailleurs je précise que quelle que
soit la zone territoriale concernée
nous avons pris en conseil de défense et
de sécurité nationale ce matin la
décision que les enterrements ne seront
pas concernés par une restriction ou une
interdiction met à nouveau je ne peux
que vous inviter à la plus grande des
vigilances
j'ai fait le choix aujourd'hui tous
présentés en détail le troisième pilier
de notre stratégie face à l'épidémie de
coronavirus qui est notre approche
déterminée
nationalement différencier territoire
par territoire pour que chacun d'entre
nous puisse comprendre la situation et
ainsi renforcer notre vigilance
si je devais résumer mon propos en
quelques diapos vous verrez je vous
dirais qu'il y a au total 69 territoire
sur notre
en france qui sont en zone de
circulation active à compter de samedi
qui est la bascule d'un certain nombre
de métropoles en zone d' alerte
renforcée et que la situation sanitaire
reste en particulier particulièrement
inquiétante en guadeloupe et à marseille
et que des mesures complémentaires
seront donc prises en conséquence dans
les 48 heures je rappelle notre
méthodologie la façon dont nous prenons
ces décisions des décisions hebdomadaire
qui sont appliquées pour au moins 15
jours avec des réveils des réévaluations
à chaque fois que cela fera sens à
chaque fois que cela sera nécessaire et
à nouveau la méthode de la concertation
qui est indispensable dans les
territoires enfin je voudrais terminer
en rappelant les consignes qui concerne
tout le monde quelle que soit la zone
dans laquelle nous nous trouvons le
respect des gestes barrières le lavage
des mains la limitation des contacts et
des rassemblements je le redis y compris
dans la sphère privée
réduisons notre nos contacts sociaux
réduisons notre bulle sociale et la
rampe et le et le renforcement des
protections de la protection des seniors
et des personnes âgées vulnérables
qu'elle soit à domicile ou qu'elle soit
en ehpad en rappelant que la protection
ne signifie pas la solitude et
l'isolément
hors de question d'en arriver à ce type
de situation
je vous remercie et je vais maintenant
prendre je crois des questions qui ont
été
pourquoi ne pas alléger les mesures dans
les ehpad alors qu'elles le sont dans
les écoles il est difficile de les
mettre en place et de s'y tenir dans la
durée
la grande différence entre les écoles et
les épate il ya beaucoup de différences
entre les écoles et les ehpad bien
évidemment c'est que les enfants sont
peu sensibles aux coronavirus et que les
experts nous disent que les enfants
transmettent peu le virus al'inverse on
le sait on l'a vécu pendant la première
vague en france comme à l'étranger
lorsque le virus rentrer dans un ehpad
et qu'il contamine un résident ou un
membre du personnel
il peut faire des dégâts considérables
faire beaucoup de malades et faire
coût de victimes il y avait hier soir
180 cluster 180 groupes de cas
identifiés dans différents et pas de
notre territoire
c'est pourquoi nous mettons en place des
mesures de vigilance particulière nous y
travaillons avec la ministre déléguée en
charge et l'autonomie
brigitte bourguignon le président de la
république l'a rappelé hier
nous voulons maintenir les visites brisé
lutter farouchement contre l'isolément
des personnes âgées mais en même temps
assurer leur protection
où en sont les traitements pour lakovic
19 qu'en est il du vaccin
côté traitement il n'y a pas de
nouveauté depuis la semaine dernière la
d'exams états zone qui est un dérivé de
la cortisone est utilisé maintenant
routine par l'ensemble des équipes qui
prennent en charge à l'hôpital des
malades qui ont des formes graves ou
susceptibles de s'aggraver du
coronavirus et l'expérience nous montre
que ce virus paix civile ce traitement
permet de réduire les cas graves et de
réduire également la mortalité
s'agissant du vaccin je le répète nous
voulons un vaccin qui soit à la fois
efficace sûr et disponible la
disponibilité elle est travaillée à
l'échelle de la commission européenne
qui a qui passent des commandes et des
pré commandes avec l'ensemble des
laboratoires qui sont susceptibles
d'identifier un vaccin à la fois sûr et
efficace
et lorsque ce vaccin existera lorsque la
recherche aura abouti je souhaite que ce
soit évidemment le plus tôt possible
nous parlerons de la façon de vacciner
de protéger la population française
comment assurer qu'on ne fasse pas la
queue trop longtemps quand on a besoin
de se faire tester c'est un point
essentiel dont j'ai beaucoup parlé la
semaine dernière avec des annonces que
je rappelle la priorisation de l'accès
aux tests diagnostiques pour les
personnes qui sont symptomatiques
adressé par leur médecin pour les
personnes qui sont qu'à contacter
identifiés comme tels ou par le médecin
de l'assurance maladie ou par les
équipes de l'agencé régionale de santé
ou par le biais du logiciel stop coville
pour les personnes qui ont eu la bonne
idée de les télécharger j'en rajoute une
couche est important de télécharger
cette application qui rend service
véritablement et pour les professionnels
de santé 1
si que les professionnels du domicile
notamment les aides à domicile gelé a
annoncé la semaine dernière j'ai demandé
aux agences régionales de santé de
travailler à cette priorisation avec
l'ensemble des laboratoires qui sont
mobilisés sur tout le territoire
national
je rappelle que nous ils réalisent plus
d'un million deux cent mille tests par
semaine désormais et j'ai pu me rendre
lundi sur ce qu'on appelle un barnum
c'est une opération de test grandeur
nature à l'extérieur des hôpitaux et des
laboratoires
c'était à mantes la jolie où chaque
barnum en ile-de-france sera capable de
faire jusqu'à 500 tests par jour il y en
a vingt au total en déploiement en ile
de france c'est à dire dix mille tests
par jour réservé aux seuls publics
prioritaires et sont ouverts de 8 heures
du matin à 14 heures et les premières
données dont je dispose notamment un
barnum dans le xiiie arrondissement de
paris et un autre barnum attrape où des
centaines de prélèvements ont été
réalisés les premiers jours les
résultats de ces tests ont été obtenus
dans les 24 heures qui ont suivi c'est
ainsi que nous devons fonctionner il est
impératif que les personnes
symptomatique que les cas contacts et
les autres publics prioritaires est un
accès facilité aux tests avec des
résultats dans les meilleurs délais
bonsoir monsieur le ministre julien van
aelst pour bfm tv
vous l'avez largement expliqués à on
voit que la situation se dégrade dans
plusieurs dans plusieurs territoires et
métropole à l'heure où je vous parle est
ce qu'aujourd'hui vous pouvez nous
confirmer qu'il n'y aura pas de
confinement même local dans ces
territoires si la situation venait à se
dégrader à nouveau votre question est
parfaitement légitime si je puis me
permettre de la caractériser ainsi
d'autant qu'on voit que certains pays
autour de nous sont amenés à mener des
actions de re confinement localiser
c'est le cas notamment dans de nombreux
quartiers de madrid en espagne
nous faisons tout pour ne pas en arriver
à des mesures de confinement même
partielle et même localiser même
territorialisées pourquoi nous prenons
des mesures qui sont des mesures fortes
et encore une fois qu'ils ont un impact
sur le quotidien des français qui vivent
dans ces territoires
c'est pour casser les chaînes de
contamination c'est pour casser la
dynamique virale avant que les systèmes
sanitaires avant que les systèmes
diagnostic et de prise en charge soit
totalement dépassé ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui nous sommes encore dans un
objectif de maîtriser l'épidémie
nous ne sommes pas dans la situation du
printemps dernier et donc nous
n'envisageons pas de confinement
vous avez noté que nous sommes en
capacité de déclencher un état d'urgence
sanitaire dans des territoires
si d'aventuré malgré toutes les mesures
qui ont été mises en place et bien un
impact sanitaire était trop important
cet état d'urgence sanitaire peut
s'accompagner d'autres types de mesures
je ne veux pas nous n'envisageons pas de
confinement généralisée et nous ne
souhaitons pas tendre dans un
confinement quelle que soit sa forme
c'est pour ça que nous devons être
extrêmement attentifs extrêmement
vigilants
oui bonjour s'il vous plaît angers
achats au sein de l'agencé de presse ap
j'ai une question concernant roland
garros dans votre travail de pédagogie
ou parler beaucoup de cohérence mais
pourquoi il ya une incohérence avec
roland garros qui ouvre dans quelques
jours il y aura un brassage de foule
tous les jours pendant 15 jours les
les groupes de plus de 10 personnes les
gens qui mangent et boire debout et
cetera
donc pourquoi les spectateurs la barre
en les règles différentes que celles où
que le public français dans l'est où le
public comme dans les autres endroits de
paris où est ce qu'il y aura les règles
les changements des règles
j'ai annoncé qu'il y aurait une
concertation pendant 48 heures entre le
préfet et donc le préfet de police de
paris en l'occurrence et les élus pour
déterminer les conditions d'application
des règles que j'ai annoncée parmi
lesquels il y a une jauge maximale à
1000 personnes pour des grands
événements donc cette concertation
le résultat de cette concertation vous
l'aurez lorsqu'elle aura eu lieu
votre question est tout à fait juste
vous pourriez m'interroger sur d'autres
événements j'ai parlé j'ai appelé
l'ensemble des maires des communes qui
sont concernés par un passage en zone d'
alerte renforcée aujourd'hui est par
exemple je me suis entretenu avec le
maire de saint-etienne de la foire
internationale de saint-etienne qui doit
se dérouler à la fin de la semaine
dès lors que nous mettons en place des
jauges et des limitations cela a
forcément un impact sur tous types de
grands événements attendons le résultat
de la concertation
bonjour et l'abonné pour été facile j'ai
juste besoin d'une précision sur la
fermeture des bars notamment à marseille
ça s'applique à partir d'aujourd'hui ou
de lundi à partir de lundi bonjour c'est
du blanc d'oeuf de la paix m vous
parliez tout à l'heure des barnums et
des tests qui tu es rendu en 24 heures
des résultats des tests qui étaient
rendus en 24 heures on a l'impression
que c'est un petit peu l'exception
alors quand est ce qu'on peut s'attendre
à ce que sur l'ensemble du territoire y
ait des délais raisonnables pour avoir
un rendez-vous et pour avoir un résultat
de son test parce que sinon on se
demande quel est l'intérêt de se faire
de se faire tester et j'avais une autre
question aussi sur les tests antigénique
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur
leur prise en charge est sûre sur leur
place dans la stratégie de dépistage
d'abord vous dire que l'échelle
nationale
55% des résultats de tests sont rendus
dans les 36 heures essais 65% ou 70% des
résultats de tests qui sont rendus dans
les 48 heures ce qui veut dire qu'il ya
encore au moins un tiers des tests qui
rendue dans un délai supérieur à 48
heures donc trop long pas dire que ça
dysfonctionne partout mais ça veut dire
qu'il est en droit en tension
particulière ces endroits sont notamment
les métropoles dans lesquelles le berry
le virus circule de plus puisque par
définition c'est là que vous avez le
plus de personnes symptomatique le plus
de cas contacts et donc ça en bouteille
et c'est pour ça que ça bouchonne plutôt
qu'en bouteille
du coup c'est notamment le cas en
ile-de-france pour ça que j'ai parlé des
vins barnum en ile de france mais dans
l'ensemble des régions qui sont
concernés des dispositions spécifiques à
chaque territoire qui passent d'ailleurs
souvent par le déploiement de ces barnum
sont mis en place pour pouvoir répondre
à cette demande qui est une demande
encore une fois légitime que je
comprends que je partage à laquelle je
m'associe pleinement et pour laquelle
nous déployons tous les moyens sur la
question des tests antigénique j'ai
saisi la haute autorité de santé pour
que sur la base des données dont elles
disposent et notamment des
expérimentations qui sont conduites dans
notre pays
je pense aux hôpitaux parisiens par
exemple depuis quelques jours la haute
autorité de santé doit rendre je
l'espère des conclusions demain soir ou
après demain
en tout état de cause il est prévu que
je puisse vous présenter la semaine
prochaine une stratégie en matière de
tests tyran conclusions des premières
mesures qui ont été déployés pour
prioriser les publics prioritaires avec
les délais d'accès également présenté la
stratégie avec les innovations je pense
au test salivaire mais également aux
tests antigénique nous prenons les deux
dernières questions je ministre j'ai un
point qui pose aujourd'hui difficulté si
la gestion des cas contacts alors je
voudrais que vous nous disiez
aujourd'hui face à un point de la
situation
combien de quel est le nombre de ces
brigades sanitaire combien de monde
aujourd'hui sont affectés à ces cas
contacts parce qu'il me semble enfin
selon les observateurs qui est vraiment
en difficulté lors il ya en moyenne
entre deux et trois cas contacts par ps
par personne positive
donc lorsque vous faites 10 mille
diagnostic pcr un jour comme aujourd'hui
ses dix mille mais c'est aux alentours
de dix mille probablement je n'avais pas
encore les chiffres
avant de venir vous
ça veut dire que vous aurez demain trois
fois plus de personnes à contacter ce
qu'on appelle le contact et racing de
traçage pour savoir avec quelle personne
vous avez été en contact étroit et que
vous avez été susceptible de contaminer
malgré vous ce traçage il repose sur
trois niveaux d'intervention les
médecins l' agence régionale de santé
l'assurance maladie votre question me
permet d'ailleurs d'inviter les
personnes qui sont diagnostiqués
positifs par test pcr à ne pas hésiter à
contacter leur médecin quand ils le
savent ils ne sont pas obligés d'aller
le voir
la télémédecine étaient les
consultations reste parfaitement
d'actualité j'ai fait en sorte qu'elle
soit prise en charge à 100% par la
sécurité sociale n'y a pas d' avance de
frais n'est pas de reste à charge faut
pas hésiter à appeler le médecin puisque
le médecin a toute sa place dans le
dispositif de traçage de tracking pour
accompagner expliqué également aux
personnes qui vont être mises à l'abri
comment cette période va se dérouler par
ailleurs nous déployons avec les agences
régionales de santé des dispositifs
d'appels ou de contacter par sms selon
les publics avec au moins deux prises de
contacts dans la semaine de mise à
l'abri et davantage évidemment c'est les
personnes sont vulnérables jeu que je
doive être question pour remercier
toutes ces équipes qui n'ont jamais
arrêté de travailler y compris au coeur
de l'été c'est un travail qui est
compliqué je remercie aussi les français
qui font preuve de civisme et qui
répondent à ces enquêtes de traçage
c'est pas toujours le cas
alors que c'est fondamental si vous êtes
positif diagnostiqués au co vide vous
devez participer à cette travail de
traçage pour protéger les personnes que
vous avez pu contaminer et si vous êtes
personnes positives au co vide
et si vous n'êtes qu'à contacter vous
devez impérativement respectées
l'isolant la mise à l'abri sur la
période de sept jours
oui bonsoir une question pour hospimedia
vous allez présenter dans quelques jours
le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale qui doit intégrer les
coûts liés à la prise en charge du gros
navires us confirmez-vous des
informations de nos confrères des échos
selon laquelle l'objectif de dépenses
d'assurance maladie 2021 va s'élever à
222 milliards et l'objectif rectifié
2020 à 215 m
merci ce que je peux vous confirmer
parce que je n'ai pas encore nous
n'avons pas présenté en conseil des
ministres le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale le
fameux budget de la sécu qui est
examinée chaque automne au parlement je
n'ai donc pas ici vous faire des
confidences devant les téléspectateurs
en revanche je peux vous confirmer deux
choses d'une part rarement voire jamais
dans l'histoire de notre pays
l'état n'aura engagé autant de dépenses
pour protéger la santé des français
et forcément c'est un impact sur
l'équilibré de l'assurance maladie
c'est le quoi qu'il en coûte les
activités de l'activité partielle pour
les personnes qui ne peuvent pas
travailler
l'achat des masques les tests dont on
parle les médicaments les
hospitalisations le soutien aux
soignants tout cela évidemment un coup
ça fera l'objet d'un débat au parlement
comme c'est le cas chaque année et nous
avons un système de protection sociale
dont la france peut être fière dont elle
peut s'enorgueillir
personne n'a été privés de soins faute
de pouvoir les payer
je cite l exemple de la télémédecine
tout à l'heure qui prix sachant en
charge à 100% par la sécurité sociale
c'est parce que nous avons un système
qui est solide que nous avons un système
protecteur
je vous remercie
dites moi
dernière question vous avez évoqué les
bars la fermeture si je me trompe pas
des débarras 22 heures c'est bien ça
vous savez pas évoquer les restaurants
est-ce que c'est également les
restaurants ou pas ou que les bars ont
fait la différence entre les bars et les
restaurants les difficultés que nous
n'avons constaté et notamment au cours
de l'été vous savez qu'il ya des mesures
qui font qu'on ne peut pas se tenir
debout sans masque dans un bar on doit
mettre son masque même lorsqu'on va se
déplacer pour aller se laver les mains
ou aller aux toilettes où elle est
passée des commandes s'est pas toujours
respectée il y en a qui le respectent et
je les en remercie les endroits où c'est
plus difficile est passée une certaine
heure le soir quand on a un peu passée
l'heure de l'apéro c'est encore plus
difficile de faire respecter cela il ya
des études qui montrent notamment des
études internationales que parmi les
personnes contaminées un plus grand
nombre avaient fréquenté un bar des
jours précédents c'est un facteur
différenciant entre les personnes qui
ont été contaminées et celles qui ne
l'ont pas été pour les restaurants la
situation est différente on voit moins
de gens debout à l'intérieur d'un
restaurant ya moins de brassage y
compris lorsque la nuit profonde est
tombé et les mesures sanitaires qui ont
été appliqués les distanciation entre
les tables et entre les groupes
permettent d'assurer leur bon
fonctionnement c'est pourquoi nous
privilégions des mesures concernant les
seuls barre dans les zones en alerte
renforcée notamment paris alors que dans
les zones où vraiment les russes
circulent trop et les personnes âgées
sont les plus touchées des eaux lde
alerte maximale là nous sommes
contraints de prendre des mesures plus
strictes
y compris incluant les restaurateurs qui
je le précise et je le répète sont
évidemment accompagnés et soutenus par
l'état je vous remercie